- You know, the quality has
always have to be bumped up.
- Right.
- You know, I'm always tryin'
to make sure more quality,
more quality, more quality.
Now, most actors are just
sitting around waiting
for somebody to say, "Hey,
you want to be in my movie?"
So, I don't like that.
Play hard, man. That's the
values we give 'em, play hard.
All my records aren't
message driven records.
All my albums aren't
message driven albums.
The beauty of Straight Out of Compton is
not that some academy
members get it, you know--
- Right.
- 'Cause they will get
anything you throw in front of them.
There's 24 hours in a day, you can
do whatever you want with 'em.
The question is, are we rock and roll?
I mean, Jonah Hill and Channing Tatum,
wouldn't they piss you off?
- He's an American
rapper, record producer,
actor and film producer.
He began his career as a member
of the hip hop group CIA and
later joined the seminal rap group NWA.
He's noted as a proficient lyricist and
story teller and regarded
as a brutally honest rapper.
He's Ice Cube, and here's my take
on his top 10 rules for success.
Rule number one is my
personal favorite, but
I'm curious to find out
which one you guys like most.
(jet engine hissing)
(explosion boom)
- What is the key to
your success you think?
'Cause you've had a lot of
wins, man, a lot of wins.
- You know, I guess respecting what
I'm doing more than getting
a win, you know what I mean?
I love the work, I love to actually get
in there and create,
and make something good.
Take something out the back of my mind and
give it a physical form
and let people enjoy it.
It's really what I get off on, so,
to do that, to be in that
mix, you know the quality has
always have to be bumped up.
- Right.
- You know, I'm always tryin'
a make sure more quality,
more quality, more quality.
You know, throughout the whole project
I'm the king of quality control.
- Are you really?
- Yes.
And I'm doing my career my way.
You know, being able to put
together your own movies is a blessing.
Now, most actors are just
sitting around waiting
for somebody to say, "Hey,
you want to be in my movie?"
So, I don't like that.
I wouldn't be an actor if I
was just sitting around, so.
I love producing, I love writing, and
just making sure it happen.
You know, you got to be proactive.
Play hard, man, that's
the values we give 'em.
Play hard and, hey man, be yourself.
You know, in this world
when everybody wants
you to be, you know, to conform
to this conform to that.
Man, my whole thing is be yourself, man,
you know everybody's a individual.
We all got different
fingerprints, different DNA.
Yo, man, we should just show
how different we are man
and just be yourself.
My message is--
You know, to me, only as good
as the person delivering it.
So, you know, the thing
is, I want to evolve
to the point where people
are hearing, you know I mean,
I don't want to evolve past the point
of people hearing what I got to say.
Hearing my message in that,
in whatever particular record
you listening to 'cause,
all my records aren't
message driven records,
all my albums aren't
message driven albums, you know.
I wouldn't even call I am the
West a message driven album,
you know what I mean, I would call
Raw Footage a message driven album, so.
It depends on how I feel,
but I think, you know,
I just don't want to
evolve past people hearing
what I got to say, 'cause,
you know, to me that's
not evolving that's
dissolving, you know, so it's
really all about making sure
the people are hearing you.
And so, you got to do what you got to do
in this climate to make sure you're heard.
The beauty of Straight Out of Compton is
not that some academy
members get it, you know--
- Right.
- 'Cause they will get
anything you throw in front of them.
They don't know if this is
authentic or not.
- Right.
- It's the hard core fans,
you know what I mean, it's
the core fans are the ones who
let you know if you got it right.
When they say, "Man, you took me back
to '87, man, I felt like,
man I could smell, you know--
- The weed.
- (laughing) Yeah, you know,
the weed.
- I went for the weed instead
- of whatever else you're thinking.
- So, but, that's cool.
(laughing)
But, you know, it's like,
that's what it's all about.
- Yeah.
- It's all about
the core fans and making
sure they satisfied and
then the fans, the fringe fans.
- Yeah.
- They got to get
in where they fit in, with me.
You know what I mean, they just
got to get in where they fit in.
I'm not going to cater too much
to a fringe fan as much as a core fan.
- That's probably the key to your success
right there too, at least one of them.
- Maybe,'cause I don't reach.
- It's
just like focusing on that, yeah.
- You know, I'm not reaching
'cause you reach so far
for that new fan, and you
come attached or detached--
- You loose yourself.
- from the core fan.
We said, you about to witness
the strength of street knowledge.
Meaning, you are about
to witness, you know,
a knowledge coming off the streets or
out the streets that you may
not have ever witnessed before.
We just wanted to be real,
we just wanted to, be honest.
Street knowledge is a
term to me, it means,
letting the streets know what
the government, politics,
police, whatever, authority
figures are, are doing
up to, exposing them and also, letting,
if the politicians are
listening, letting them know
what the streets think and
how things are going and
hopefully, there's some understanding
that can be made in all this.
And you got to bring
a effort to the table.
You can't look for the world
to make your life better.
You've got to make your life better.
You got to bring in them grades.
You got to do that work and it's
hard work doing everything that we do.
Nothing's easy, not even for a rapper,
movie actor, whatever you want to do and
it's all hard, and there's times where
I don't want to get up,
and I don't want to do it.
But I got to do it,
because this is my life.
And you got to make those choices, and,
you know, like I said, and
I'mma end my little spiel
right here, there's 24 hours in a day,
you can do whatever you want with 'em.
Whatever you want, you can waste 'em, or
you can do something that's
going to help your life.
Because you will grow up,
everybody here will grow up, and
you will have to deal
with all the problems that
all the grown people
around you are telling
you that you going to have to deal with.
It's no fairy tale, it's no lie.
It's hard out there.
Down for Whatever is one of them
underrated joints on second side.
- Definitely.
- You know but--
- It just comes man, tell them,
tell them the flavor of it
cause it just (snaps fingers).
- It's one of them slow flows,
you know, that everybody into.
- Yeah.
- So, a lot of people
when I played it for them,
they didn't even know that was me.
They was like, "Who is that?"
You know.
- Word.
- I was like, yo, that's me.
- It's dope.
- You always got
to give people what they don't expect.
The question is, are we rock and roll?
(audience cheering)
And I say, you God damned
right we rock and roll.
(audience cheering and whistling)
See, rock and roll is not a instrument.
Rock and roll is not
even a style of music.
Rock and roll is a spirit. It's a spirit.
(audience cheering and clapping)
It's been going since the
blues, jazz, bebop, soul, R&B,
rock and roll, heavy metal,
punk rock, and yes, hip hop.
(audience cheering)
And what connects us all is that spirit.
That's what connects us all. That spirit.
Rock and roll is not
conforming to the people
who came before you but creating
your own path in music and in life.
That is rock and roll and that is us.
(audience cheering)
So, rock and roll is not
conforming, rock and roll is
outside the box and rock and roll is NWA.
I want to thank everybody
who helped induct us
into the rock and roll hall of fame and
I just want to tell the world,
damn that (beep) was dope.
Thank you.
You are very good at seeming angry.
I don't know if you are angry in general.
(audience laughing)
But, in the movies,
in 21 and 22 Jump Street.
- Yeah.
- You're disgusted with--
- I mean, Jonah Hill and Channing Tatum,
wouldn't they piss you off?
(laughing)
- So, I thought it would be
fun if I gave you some lines.
Now, these are not lines that
you, you would not classify
these lines as your typical,
like, kind of angry guy lines.
In fact, they're quite
the opposite of that.
- Okay.
- And I'll read
them to you, and then if
you act them back to me,
in your own inimitable way, okay?
- Okay.
- You want to do that?
(audience cheering)
Alright, say these as angrily as you can.
Lavender body wash makes my pores tingle.
(dramatic music)
- Lavender body wash make my pores tingle.
(audience cheering)
- I know right.
There's nothing better on a
gloomy day than a good book,
a warm blanket, and a
creamy pumpkin bisque.
(audience laughing)
(dramatic music)
- Man, it's nothing better on a gloomy day
than a warm, what was it
a, a good blanket, a warm--
Man, gimmie some damn pumpkin brisk.
(audience cheering)
You know I went to the LA
Unified School District,
so I can't read that good.
- You know what, you did it well.
(audience laughing)
- Okay.
- You did it well.
- Alright, alright.
- Here's another one for ya.
I want a love like the
love in The Notebook,
a love that splits the sky.
- I want a love like the
love in The Notebook,
the one that split the sky, man.
(audience cheering)
Split the sky.
- This is wonderful, and this is great
for young actors as well.
It's an exercise, alright,
one more are you ready?
- Let's do it.
- O-M-G, did you do something
new with your hair? I love it.
(audience laughing)
- O-M-G, did you do something
with your hair? I love it.
I love it.
(audience cheering)
- That's Ice Cube everybody,
that's acting right there.
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
Marcel Williams asked me to.
So, if there is a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next, leave it down
on the comments below and
I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which if Ice Cube's
top 10 rules had the biggest
impact on you and why.
Leave it in the comments and
I will join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe,
and I'll see you soon.
(jet engine hissing)
(explosion boom)